- All right everybody.
We've reached the end of the hour,
but there's just enough time
for one more great story.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
Spring is just around the corner
and that means our national parks
will soon be filled with visitors.
I love national parks.
A New Jersey teen wants to inspire
more people of color to visit
so she's written a children's book
called "Find Your Forest,"
that explores the magic
of the great outdoors
'cause it is very magical, y'all.
We have her dialed in.
Say hello to 16-year-old Audrey
who watches on NBC New York.
Hi, Audrey.
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- So Audrey, I'm with you.
I love National Parks so much.
I literally feel like I
live in one in Montana,
but what inspired you to do this?
- Yeah, so I grew up in Brooklyn, New York
and living in Brooklyn it
really felt like forests
were some mystical, far away
place from where I lived.
And when I got a little bit
older, we moved to New Jersey
and I was fortunate enough to
live very close to a forest.
So, I spent a lot of time there
and really just realized
how incredible it is
to spend time in nature.
It would calm me down and
allow me to clear my head.
And so, I started doing
some research on this
and I discovered something
called the Nature Gap.
And what this is is only about 10%
of National Park visitors
are people of color.
And as a Latina myself,
this was something that really shocked me.
So with this book, I
wanted to inspire kids
and families from all backgrounds
to get out into the forests.
- The Earth, it's amazing, it's magical.
And to be a part of it is amazing.
So who did you work with to do this?
- Yeah, so I had the wonderful opportunity
to work with forest educators
at the US Forest Service,
along with a bilingual
children's media company
called Encantos and the Ad Council
who are the folks that
brought us Smokey the Bear.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And with them I really
wanted to make sure
I was accurately portraying the animals,
plants, and insects that I
was demonstrating in the book.
And not only did we want
this to be educational,
but also fun.
So, we have an activities
list in the back of the book
and one of my personal favorites
is something called sound mapping.
And sound mapping is
when you close your eyes
and you listen to the
forest sounds around you
and you draw everything
out on a piece of paper.
And with this book, I really hope
that I can go out into my local forest
or forests around the country
and see families of all colors
enjoying the forest as much as I do.
- This is so cool, two
different languages right here,
"Find Your Forest" is on
sale exclusively at Target.
Y'all be sure to get a copy.
Thank you so much, Audrey.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(audience cheering)
- [Audrey] Thank you.
- And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly
just like you, ma'am,
so they're gonna give you
$1,000 just for being rad.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much, Audrey.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Sir Rod Stewart, Jools
Holland, Camila Mendes,
Chef Scott, and Melissa.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, change it.